John why don't we see more team writing
when it comes to film that we see in
television I wish we would see it the
only place where we have that in film on
a regular basis is in Pixar and it just
so happens I don't think by coincidence
that the best scripts day in day out
year after year come from Pixar best
writing of any studio in Hollywood by
far not even close why because they use
the technique
that TV is based on which is team
writing instead of individual writing
now there's tremendous advantage to
having an individual writer because you
get the vision unique voice of that
person coming through the story and you
don't want to lose that however where
you get this tremendous value that you
get from team writing that we see in
television is in terms of breaking the
story the requirement to get this story
right in television is the beyond the
end-all
you do not get to go to script until
everybody is satisfied but of course
especially the showrunner is satisfied
then that that that that story is broken
down into the beats and that those beats
are sequence properly because the
perception that many writers have
screenplays is all fix it in the rewrite
well on TV we've learned that isn't true
that doesn't happen you don't fix it in
the rewrite if you have structured the
story in a certain way with the cards
the that's going to be embedded in the
script and then changing it is much more
difficult when it's been written as a
script then if you change it when it's
simply a sequence of story beats and
that this is the great thing that you
learn when you write on a writing staff
so
Pixar understands that and they have
writers working together too and they
make sure that they're not going to go
to animation until that story is great
and that that script is great and so why
don't other Studios do it it's because
the way the economics of the system
works you can do that in animation when
you have a company like Pixar that has
been set up that way but the way the
normal Hollywood studio works is that
each of these films is a freelance
situation each has its writer its
director its actors and so on and so
forth and so they're unable to do this
team writing concept and in a way we
have to go back to the Golden Age of
Hollywood in the 30s and 40s when we had
the studio system and then you had a
very similar type of situation where you
had writers working for the studio and
they would get all the assignments and
you'd have writers who had the kind of
experience when they would write a one
of the great writers like Manhattan who
would would have written 70 plus films
where is now with the freelance system
in film even the most experienced top
writers maybe maybe they've got five
films to their name produced films maybe
ten if they're so really good and
they're really at the top whereas on TV
when you work on staff you're generating
these things at a tremendous pace and if
the show is successful over 5 plus
seasons so the amount of craft that you
have but you then apply to the next show
that you write just keeps getting higher
and higher and the great thing that you
get with staff writing and that you get
with television is when you write that
TV episode four weeks later it's airing
and you get to see it and you get to see
how did it work where did it fail
I remember when when we would look at
the episodes of Jump Street some of them
we would say that's just a great script
that was a great episode was a great
show and some we would say that's just
one of the worst pieces of television
we've ever done but it's because but
both of those were valuable because we
get that feedback immediately as a
screenwriter you write a script maybe
three years later it gets comes out as a
film probably not very much the way not
very close to the way you wrote it so
the the what you can learn from that
experience as a writer much less
you